lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
familiarizarnos con la gráfica de
tangente de teta para esto voy a dibujar
aquí un pequeño círculo unitario que nos
permita visualizar la tangente para
diversos valores de teta este es mi eje
y y este de aquí es mi eje x este es el
eje x y el círculo unitario se va a ver
más o menos más o menos así y como ya
sabemos este es un recordatorio de la
definición del círculo unitario que si
tengo un ángulo que se forma a partir de
la parte positiva del eje x este sería
el lado terminal formando así este
ángulo theta sabemos que las coordenadas
del punto donde el rayo terminal
intersecta el círculo unitario están
dadas por seno de theta no perdón la
coordenada en x es el coseno coseno de
theta coma seno de teta así es que la
coordenada en x aquí es coseno beteta
mientras que la coordenada en yes seno
de teta nos interesa tangente de teta
pero como ya sabemos tangente de t t es
igual a seno de teta sobre jose no
detecta o iniciando desde el origen y si
tomamos el valor de la coordenada en g
si tomamos el valor de la coordenada en
jets sobre la coordenada en x estamos
obteniendo la pendiente de esta recta
pues básicamente estamos calculando el
cambio en g
sobre el cambio en x ésta de aquí es la
pendiente la pendiente de esto que
podemos llamar el radio terminal del
ángulo teta esto nos va a permitir
visualizar cuáles son los diversos
valores que toma la tangente déjame
borrar un poco este círculo unitario
para que nos sirva nuevamente ahí está
ahora hagamos una tabla hagamos una
tabla aquí
así es que para diversos valores de
theta veamos cuánto vale la tangente de
teta el más fáciles cuando teta es igual
a 0 radiales sitet es igual a cero
radiales cuál es la pendiente de este
rayo la pendiente del rayo es cero
cuando cambia x no hay cambio en y ahora
pensemos en voy a tomar valores de theta
para los cuales no va a ser fácil
calcular la pendiente del rayo y con
esto nos vamos a dar una idea de la
forma que tiene la gráfica de tangente
de teta tomemos ahora el valor de pi
sobre 4 tomemos ahora dt iguala y sobre
4 radiales así es que este ángulo teta
es igual a pi sobre 4 o lo que es lo
mismo
dt igual a 45 grados pero que lo
interesante de este valor para este
ángulo la coordenada en xy la coordenada
en ye de este punto es la misma recuerda
que ambas son raíz de 2 sobre 2 lo
importante es que el avance que tienes
en la dirección de x es el mismo que
tienes en la dirección de y así es que
la pendiente del rayo terminal va a ser
igual a 1 es decir la tangente de teta
va a ser igual a 1 como el seno de tete
y el coche no beteta son iguales la
tangente de teta es igual a 1 si ahora
tenemos déjame limpiar aquí porque voy a
estar utilizando este círculo unitario
bien ya vimos que sitet es igual a pi
sobre 4 la tangente de teta es igual a 1
ahora qué pasa si ted es igual a menos y
sobre 4 en este caso aquí es donde se
ubica el radio terminal así es que
cuando x déjame dibujar un pequeño
triángulo aquí la coordenada en x aquí
es raíz de 2 sobre 2 ya lo sabemos lo
hemos visto varias veces raíz de dos
sobre mejor deja de poner etiquetas que
sean más claras el ángulo que se forma
aquí es tt igual a menos pi sobre 4
radiales o si lo prefieres menos 45
grados pero ahora el seno y el coseno de
este ángulo van a tener signos opuestos
el coseno del ángulo
a raíz de 2 sobre 2 la coordenada en x
de la intersección en este punto
mientras que la coordenada en que es
menos raíz de 2 sobre dos menos raíz de
2 sobre 2 y cuál es el valor de la
tangente bien va a ser el seno sobre el
coseno que es igual a menos 1 y aquí lo
podemos ver para cada avance en la
dirección positiva de x vamos a tener el
mismo avance en la dirección negativa de
y otra vez voy a borrar esto pues voy a
seguir utilizando este círculo unitario
bien ahí lo tenemos esto es igual a
menos 1 hemos encontrado que la tangente
de menos pi sobre 4 es igual a menos 1
por lo pronto vayamos graficando estos
puntos si este de aquí es el eje z no sé
si se puede ver bien eso es el eje teta
y este de aquí es el eje y ese es el eje
y tenemos que tangente de cero es igual
a cero
tangente de pi sobre 4 radiales es igual
a 1 y tangente de menos y sobre 4 es
igual a menos 1 y aquí viendo tan solo
estos puntos podrías pensar que es una
recta pero no ya veremos claramente que
no es una recta porque qué pasa a medida
que el ángulo se acerca a medida que el
ángulo se acerca cada vez más a pi sobre
2 qué pasa con la pendiente de esta
recta así es que este este está que se
está acercando cada vez más a pi sobre 2
y mientras tanto el radio terminal se
está acercando a la vertical la
pendiente va tomando valores positivos
que son cada vez mayores la pendiente al
llegar el ángulo a pi sobre 2 no está
definida pero podemos decir que tiende
infinito
a medida que el ángulo se acerca a pi
sobre 2 así es que cuando teta vale pi
sobre 2 voy a dibujar aquí una asiento
está vertical aquí en pi sobre 2 para
indicar de alguna manera que la tangente
se está acercando infinito sin llegar a
alcanzar el valor así es que la gráfica
se va
más o menos así más o menos así se va a
ver la pendiente de este rayo a medida
que el ángulo se acerca y sobre 2 es
cada vez mayor tiende a infinito ahora
qué pasa cuando el ángulo se está
acercando cada vez más a menos
pi sobre 2 se está acercando cada vez
más a menos y sobre 2 en este caso la
pendiente se está haciendo cada vez más
y más y más negativa es decir está
atendiendo a menos infinito déjame
dibujar eso de nueva cuenta aquí la
tangente no está definida
tenemos una sin tota vertical ente está
igual a menos y sobre 2 nos estamos
aproximando cuando theta se acerca a
menos pi sobre 2 nos estamos aproximando
a menos infinito y así es como se ve la
gráfica de la tangente en esta sección
en este intervalo para ser más precisos
del eje x y así podemos continuar porque
cuando nuestro ángulo cruza pi sobre 2
cuando el ángulo es ligeramente mayor a
pi sobre 2 aquí lo tenemos pero ahora
cuál es la pendiente de esta recta la
pendiente aquí tiene un valor negativo
muy grande
se parece mucho a la que acabo de
dibujar aquí muy negativa la gráfica
brinque entonces hasta acá donde la
tangente tiene un valor negativo muy
grande un valor negativo muy grande ya
medida que aumentamos teta el valor de
la pendiente es cada vez menos y menos
negativa hasta que llegamos a este valor
este valor que es déjame ponerlo mejor
hasta que teta alcanza este valor que
tenemos aquí y cuál es este ángulo bueno
no te he dicho cuál es este ángulo bueno
digamos que este ángulo es 3 pi sobre 4
y porque 3 piso break 4 bien si aquí
tenemos pi sobre 2 y si este ángulo mide
peas sobre 4 la suma de los ángulos es 2
y sobre 4 más y sobre 43 pi sobre 4 y
este ángulo porque es interesante pues
porque de nueva cuenta nos encontramos
con un triángulo que tiene ángulos y
sobre 4 y sobre 4 ipi sobre 2 o 45 45 90
donde la longitud de los catetos xy son
iguales nada más que en este caso la
coordenada en x es negativa
mientras que la coordenada n es positiva
así es que la pendiente aquí es la misma
que teníamos cuando theta era igual a
menos pi sobre 4 radiales es decir una
pendiente de menos 1 así es que cuando
te test igual a 3 pieces sobre 4 la
pendiente es menos 1 si te está se
incrementa para llegar aquí la pendiente
vuelve a ser 0 la pendiente vuelve a ser
0 ahora si incrementamos el valor de
teta en y sobre 4 radiales como vemos
aquí la pendiente vuelve a tomar el
valor de 1 la pendiente la tangente del
ángulo nuevamente vale 1 y de nueva
cuenta a medida que teta se acerca al
valor de 3 y sobre 2 el valor de la
pendiente se hace cada vez más grande es
decir tiende a infinito aquí si apenas
te mueves en la dirección de x tienes un
gran incremento en la dirección de iu de
nueva cuenta la gráfica se va a ver más
o menos así déjame ponerlo en un color
que la puedas ver claramente la gráfica
se va a ver
más o menos más o menos así y esta forma
este patrón de la gráfica se va a
repetir cada cada pi radiales
voy a hacer aquí mejor una línea
punteada se va a repetir cada irradian
es así es que vamos a dibujarla aquí
antes a quien menos pi también vale 0
voy a dibujar está sin tota de aquí y
aquí tenemos este punto y este otro
punto así es que la gráfica de tangente
de teta se va a ver más o menos más o
menos así ya vimos que es periódica por
lo cual esto se repite en ambas
direcciones